merci madame la présidente monsieur le
sénateur je veux bien croire que votre
langue a fourché dit madame la ministre
vous parler d'accord d'accord vous
voulez qu'on rende dans ce débat là je
suis absolument désolé mais je vous
demande de m'appeler madame la ministre
c'est comme ça non je ne veux pas vous
m'appeliez chers amis je m'appelais
madame la ministre
et bien alors commandes comment
pouvez-vous prétendre à leur répondre et
parler au nom des français vont parler
d' aspiration des français mais une
aspiration des français c'est l'égalité
femmes-hommes monsieur le sénateur c'est
ça la réalité c'est non seulement
l'égalité femmes-hommes
mais c'est aussi sait aussi que nous
répondions la certaine à certaines de
leurs mais je fais comme vous je fais
comme vous parfois je fais comme vous
parfois je profite d'une tribune pour
parler d'un tout autre sujet et en
l'occurrence là il est ancré dans la
réalité monsieur le sénateur je vous
demande de m'appeler
madame la ministre le débat est clos
c'est comme ça et pas autrement
pour répondre à votre question sur la
transition écologique